all right hot breath averse welcome back
to hot breath the show where you learn
comedy from the pros
i am your host comedian joel byers and
we here at hot breath
are on a mission to cultivate the next
generation of great
self-made comics and our guest today
has paved a path for us all to follow
back when she started comedy
the first joke she ever wrote in a free
comedy class at her church
ends up going viral and what ensues
is a self-made comedy empire that we are
all so
excited to learn from so without further
ado welcome to the hot breath of verse
the one and only miss angela johnson
everyone let's give it up for angela
everyone
that's so funny that like getting to
interview comics at your level like even
jeff foxworthy was like
i was hearing that intro like well who
is he about to bring to the stage
it's like even at your level you still
have that mindset
um
no you're great no we appreciate it and
people are saying that
they can't hear you so let me see what's
happening here
after that whole um i think it's
something on my end
let me
i think it's just like um i think it's
on my end i'm gonna um see
give it a shot now hello testing one two
three
there we go all right we can hear you
now that was on my end
going through zoom there's always
something you have to like
patch i'm a comedian i'm not i.t but i'm
figuring it out here
they can they can watch the replay of
what i just said yes
this will be on the podcast as well she
was basically saying yeah
focus on yourself and what you can do
yes and something you really do focus on
is
family um which i really am mindful of
in my career even
backstage we were like sharing our dogs
with each other and i know you take your
dogs on tour and all that
and what i wanted to jump into first was
with a question
from my mom as we're speaking of family
she's a huge fan my sis i'm a huge fan
our family
is a huge fan and i really learned from
you
also just from your pursuit of making
wanting to entertain everyone and
keeping it family friendly and all of
that
but to focus on family and the influence
my mom has had a huge influence
on my comedy and i know yours she didn't
really like you watching bet comic view
and things like that
but was there something that she said to
you
or advice she gave you or someone else
in your family that kind of
was a like a jumping off point for your
career
well um i would say when i decided that
i was going to move
to hollywood and pursue my dreams
my sister was really the only one that
was like
yes go for it like do it
and and it wasn't even like she was like
oh my god yes you're gonna be the most
famous person in the world like you're
so talented go get it it wasn't even
that it was just like why not
yeah go try go try
and like that is so empowering
when you can be like in your head about
a big decision that you need to make
and just to have a person like confirm
like why not why not you
yeah you know like that is just like
all the weight goes and you go oh yeah
why not me if she can do it if he can do
it how come i can't
you know like so i think it was my
sister probably being like yes go
try it do it but did you have like
imposter syndrome is something a lot of
us
struggle with especially you first joke
you write goes viral i mean there's
time in between there but it's like did
you have imposter syndrome you had to
overcome
every day every day especially because
exactly what you just said like
i skyrocketed off of a viral video
and for me
i did the work afterwards and i wrote
material and i toured and i hustled
but getting to that like break i know
there's so many comics
who went through years and years of
you know mc feature like driving their
car
six hours just to get a 15 minute spot
and then when they get there they bomb
but then they still drive
six hours to the next one and like you
know people
like really paid some dues to get to
where
i was starting so i knew
that my dues looked differently
and it was kind of like when i
got to where i was that's when the work
ethic came in because sometimes if you
hit success too
soon you don't have the character to
sustain it
you don't have the work ethic to sustain
it but
for me i i had those things
i had a good head on my shoulders i had
my intentions right i had work ethic i
had
character i had faith i had um
all of those things that sustained where
i was
and i had my eye on the prize i had
goals i wasn't
swayed by like party over here or let's
just get wasted and then
wake up late for a press the next
morning or whatever like
i was very responsible with this gift
that i had been
given and made sure that i stewarded it
well
so that i could continue to grow and and
earn things from there you know sounds
like you're very organized
i mean sure yeah
you said you have goals a lot of times
comics are like well i'll just do this
six hour gig for 50 bucks because that's
what we got to do but it seems like with
the internet
and you're an example of that we can
create our own success
with the right intention behind it yeah
yeah yeah
intention um eye on the prize like
bigger picture understanding like
maybe you you put all this work into
creating this video
and it doesn't go viral that doesn't
mean give up
that just means make a few more because
when somebody sees that and goes oh
that's kind of funny i wonder if they
have anything else and they look for
something
else like well that's kind of funny too
and then i'm gonna follow them on
instagram just
and see and then like a couple months
later you show up in their feed
and then here's your other video that
you just made that is funnier than the
other ones and now they're like oh my
god i'm going to send this one to all my
friends
but if you were like oh see i put all
this work into this video it didn't even
go viral
only got like 30 views on it like people
don't like it like
you you keep creating because you are a
creative person
and you put your creative art out there
and then if people respond to it they
respond to it it's really like
that's not your business what they
respond to if you're creating as a
creative person when you put your
authentic self
out there hopefully people respond to
like oh that's good
but the second you start creating to
impress them
to get their validation to get their
view everybody's different you're not
for everybody so then you're gonna get
insecure like
it didn't work like i was trying to be
what they wanted me to be and it didn't
work
well nobody wants you to be they want
you to be you
like show up and be you when i first
started stand up i was trying to pretend
i was super mexican
and i would all my early jokes when i
talk about my mom and my dad they have
an
accent and they're very like i mean you
threw the ball over there and like all
this stuff
my mom does not speak spanish at all my
dad does not speak spanish i'm fourth
generation
mexican and it wasn't until i started
like
owning that i still have people that
their favorite jokes of mine
is the one where um it's one of my first
jokes
and i'm talking about my mom and dad and
their very spanish accent and
how i spank everybody's kids because
that's how mexican people do it and
i still have people are like oh my god
that's like my favorite joke and i was
like wow that's like my first one when i
wasn't even being true to myself but
thank you i'm glad you responded to it
and liked it
because i knew it was funny it made
people laugh it just wasn't
me but when i started owning me
and being just me not who i thought they
wanted me to be but owning
i don't speak spanish let me write a
joke about how i don't speak spanish
instead of pretending
that i speak spanish and hope they don't
catch me so when i started owning that
and being true to who i am people
respond to authenticity
people respond to that truth and so
that's when i really started to see like
more growth ooh how do you tap into that
authenticity
i mean let's think about who are you
what makes you happy what makes you sad
what
what is your trauma from childhood do
you have any
um what is the thing that gives you
anxiety do you get anxiety
what is your quirk what is the thing
like eminem yourself
like from eight mile where he comes into
the battle
and he just disses himself
before the other guy can he's like yeah
i'm this i'm poor i'm this
all these things and what's that guy
going to say you don't have anything to
say now you just clowned yourself
so it's like think about what are all
the things about you that
self-deprecating
not in a way where it's like everybody
is like oh bummered should we give this
guy some antidepressant pills like he
really needs some help like not
necessarily in that way but
finding the joy in making fun of
yourself
before someone else can like let me just
be vulnerable and authentic
like i'm bow legged that's not real sexy
like i'm insecure about my bow legs like
when i put my feet together look they do
this
and then i show everybody like so if
somebody's in the audience looking like
oh she's super bowlegged and then i go
you guys i'm bowling
like look what happens with my legs like
i look like a camel
and like all these things and it's like
oh my god she does look like a camel
and whatever it is it's like i'm being
authentic to who i am
because i actually am insecure about
my bow legs like if i wasn't insecure
about it didn't care then i won't
pretend to be insecure about it
but i actually am so let me just be
honest about that
i'm insecure that i don't speak i'm
embarrassed that i don't speak spanish
everybody stop looking at me i'm
embarrassed
like that i've done that on stage before
because that's my actual feelings like
i'm embarrassed that i don't speak
spanish and everybody's looking at me
and they're judging me stop judging me
everybody
and that's just being authentic that's
just being what i actually think can
feel
yeah that's what ron funtious told us on
here was he really found a breakthrough
when he started talking about
what embarrassed him that's good
yeah so just being willing to tap into
that
i guess it gets easier the more you do
it i would imagine but it's first
setting the intention to write about
embarrassing things
that's good that's a good note for even
me writing more material like
what embarrasses me do you do pen to
paper
like are you a writer writer writer
or write a writer writer okay i have my
notes in my phone
um and i started this
note so long ago that i don't even know
like there's jokes in here from my like
hour special like two hours ago
as like premises right
but i just like it just goes
[Laughter]
and these are like all like my notes but
then when i'm
actually writing out like my set list i
do that on
paper and i write out my set list so i
can organize
i like my sets every story kind of flows
into the next like whatever this story
is however that ends that sentence
is going to lead you into the next story
so i i like to
have my set like that's all write it out
um every now and then i will
write out the actual words of the joke
um
but i like to say it out loud and audio
record myself
um because i like to listen back to it
if i'm driving
i'll listen to myself so i have like
these are all my voice notes here
and like i just record my ideas i record
my sets of my show
let me show you how far back this goes i
have
i recorded up i did a show at paula
casino
in march 19 2016.
that's how far back it goes that's my
audio from that show
wow virginia beach june 2016.
new jersey september 2016 like
do you listen to all of your sets are
you that disciplined
so not all of them but i keep them i
record them in the event that i say
something
funny crowd work that i want to remember
and
so this one time uh
sometimes i get uninspired to write
anything and i just coast on what i have
and um i got to this show
is in virginia beach actually and i'm on
stage and then my memory it starts
coming back to me like i remember the
stage i remember this
room i remember the tables here and the
tables here so i'm on stage and i'm
saying this
joke and as i say the joke
i remember i have said this joke in this
room before
so right in that moment i'm remembering
uh oh
am i doing the whole same show that i
did last time i was here like that is
not good
so i finished doing the show i start
adding in a little crowd work just in
case i'm like just in case i already did
this show here let me just like do some
crowd work and have something special
happen in that moment for the show
i get off stage i go straight to the
green room and i pull out my phone
and i look for my audio from the last
time i was in virginia beach and i
listened to it and sure enough
i was doing almost the same exact show
and i was like
oh my god this is not good i cannot do
this
that night i go and i start going
through my premises
what what premises do i have that i have
not even worked on because i need to
start
let me think of one punchline and at
least say that and then start doing some
crowd work and like work it out on stage
and then it becomes like my open mic
kind of so like the second show is like
all right here's a premise let's hope
something funny comes out and then the
next day
i go to coffee with my opener with my
road manager and then we sit there i'm
like okay you guys here's my premises
help me go somewhere with this this is
what i'm thinking and they're like okay
well have you thought about this like oh
that's good let me try that and then now
we go back into writing mode and now
the weekend has turned into a writing
weekend and not a coasting weekend
do you collaborate on your writing a lot
i started to incorporate collaborating
in the last
four years for sure because
um one i love community
and i love uh bouncing ideas and
i love when somebody gives me a tag like
i'm not the comedian that gets offended
by that sometimes i won't take it
because i'm like oh that's actually not
my voice like
i see what you're going with but that's
not my voice
but i feel like when i have i have very
few
guys that i work with that know my voice
so that as soon as i get off stage when
they pitch me something i'm like oh my
god
yes i would so say that and so
when i started embracing that instead of
being prideful
no this is just me here's another thing
too about being prideful
i felt like i had something to prove
because i was a girl
doing stand-up and because i blew up so
quickly
so for a long time i was trying to prove
i'm doing this on my own
like nobody's helping me nobody's ghost
writing for me
nobody's showing up like and doing the
job for me
i am doing this so it was like i was
trying to prove to people
like no i can do this but then after a
while
it was becoming like
exhausting um if i was feeling
not motivated to write then i started
developing an unhealthy relationship
with writing
because my motivation to write was shame
and guilt because i should have a new
joke by now
i should be a creative person how come
you're not using your creativity to be
writing like this is a gift that you
have like
how come you're not doing it and then
all this guilt and shame to try to
motivate oh you're right self i should
be
i should be doing that and then so i
start writing as opposed to
embracing where you are and feeling
joy for your gift and letting the
overflow
of joy in your life be what ends up on
paper
you know so i felt like when i was doing
it on my own
my motivation was like i don't really
have anything
but i need to find something like okay
and write it out
when i'm just out living my life with
people that i trust my openers that i
trust
my friends that i trust and we go and we
have coffee the next day
after a friday night show and we sit in
a coffee shop for four hours
and we're just talking and they're
helping me figure out my premise and
we're like
laughing telling childhood stories and
we're like that's good you gotta try
that tonight like okay good
like that feels good and that's fun and
that's exciting to go on stage and try
it that night
and be like okay so that one didn't work
like what else could i do and
that collaborative energy is fun for me
um but it took a while to get to that
place of putting my pride down
and who cares what other people think
about my process you know yeah that's
why we do
a daily writing club every day here at
hot breath
is we live stream a random word and then
we write a new joke in 10 minutes it's
called the right ten club
and it's like a collaborative like
community just trying to write a new
joke
in every single day it's been it's been
a great community builder for sure
i love that and then who gets to say the
joke what do you do it just live
we post them in the facebook group and
people can give each other feedback
and likes and things like that and i'll
read them live on the air on youtube
and give feedback on them as well okay
so everybody so you say
the word the word is water and then
everybody writes their own joke about
water we set a 10 minute timer and then
we all write for 10 minutes and then we
have like a new joke at the end
jokes you know sometimes i'm like i'm
i'm hosting this and people are writing
jokes like
so it's amazing the amount of comics
we've been able to like connect around
the world in here
and it's been humbling to write a new
joke in 10 minutes i'm like i've been
doing this 10 years and i'm trying to
figure out how to make this funny it's
just it's a good experience
that is so cool what a great idea
it really started with quarantine of
like all my road work disappeared
so i was like well i need some sort of
accountability accountability let me
start writing online
and now it grew into this writing club
in this community and
us meeting without without uh the
community we would not have met
yet so it's great i love that i love
that
how many people are in that club we have
2 000 people
in our facebook group the the club gets
around
we've been around 80 to 90 right now
live streaming riding together
and that's what we're you talking about
community and comedy and that's
something that like
i knew when i started out 10 years ago
it was a lot of competition
i wasn't the cool kid in my scene you
know it was just a lot of like
i don't know he may be funny but it does
he have an ironic beard can he get on
this show type deal you know
so i always just focused on getting
funny first
and that's why now this community is
like the scene i wish existed when i
started
yeah that's so cool i feel like um
so community is big to me but it's so
interesting because when i first started
i had too much anxiety and
fear to embrace the stand-up community
if that makes sense
like um i would go
to the you know
the improv in hollywood to the comedy
store or laugh factory
and i would have too much
like i would project on to people oh
they don't like me
because i blew up so fast
and they're judging me or they don't
think i'm funny because they're like
super all
popular comics and i'm like making
accents
and stuff like that so they probably
don't respect me
or like me um i don't know that i don't
know any friends there like i don't have
any friends when i get there i'm not
gonna know anybody
so i'll just not go
and then there would be times where i
would force myself to go i'm not even
joking i would have diarrhea every
single time
because i was so nervous i'm not joking
i would like be ready to gag and like
throw up
and like doing like breathing on my way
to the local club scene
because i had so much anxiety of
being there and
i remember i would go to my manager
and be like should i be spending more
time at the clubs
like when i come home from the road and
he was like
no like you don't need to you're
you're on the road it's fine and he
would be like it's catty anyways they're
everybody's just competing with
themselves like
with with each other they're just
competing with each other like it's you
you're already doing what you're
supposed to be doing
and i'd be like oh okay cool like it was
just like my out that i needed like i
just needed somebody to co-sign that i
don't need to be going to the clubs to
hang out
so i was like okay cool then i won't go
there yeah that's a good idea i'm
already
like i'm already on the road i'm doing
what i'm supposed to be doing
but really there was a part of me
that desired it that wanted
the friends wanted the camaraderie
wanted all and watching the um
the comedy store documentary yeah
on what is it showtime yeah watching
that was so inspiring and then also i
got sad at the same time because i was
like man
i wish i would have faced my fear i wish
i would have
not given in to anxiety i wish i would
have just showed up more
and challenged myself and made more
friendships and relationships and i have
friends now
in in comedy but i i don't have
that like we grew up together in this
club
feeling you know like we both started
here and
and now look at us here like i don't
have that
with people um and so that kind of makes
me sad a little bit so if anybody
listening right now who gets nervous
going to hang out at the club
i would challenge you face your fears
face your nerves face your anxiety
and just go and just show up and just
talk to people and make relationships
and
try not to judge because we're all just
doing our best to be funny
and bring joy so it's so
tough to like it's like it seemed like
what happened to you
is like a blessing and a curse and that
like
you had 12 minutes of material now nail
salon
or wait which one went viral that took
you on the road
nail salon first right because i then
knew mad tv and then bonk weequies so
then
you have 12 minutes that you wrote it a
free class at a church
now you're a headliner with 12 minutes i
mean that's like
that's unheard of until you like so
that's like
it's tough to say i should do this path
everyone else does when it's like
they're maybe thinking but angela just
went viral and she's selling out
everywhere i need to be doing that you
know so there's always two sides
to the coin there exactly and i wish i
would have
looked at it that way back then but
instead i was just like i'm nervous
anxiety i don't feel good when i go to
the club so
no i don't need to go bye in florida
sold out by the way yeah here come my
sold out shows i don't want to do this
open mic i'm selling out around the
country you know
what was that transition though you have
12 minutes now you're a headliner
i would imagine there were some epic
bombs in there somewhere
you know what's funny not too many
yeah had some for sure
but i feel like
if i was bombing i wouldn't keep doing
it
like it wasn't i don't like doing things
that i'm not good at
and i know a lot of comics are like well
this is my dream this is all i've ever
wanted so even if i bomb i can't wait to
try again and get better and get better
stand up was
not my dream and not the thing i wanted
it felt like
like something that i fell into
and um it felt like stand-up chose me
more than i chose stand-up
and so if i was bombing and not doing
well
i wouldn't keep doing it because i
didn't move to hollywood to be a
stand-up i moved to hollywood to be an
actress and i thought i was gonna be on
law order svu
and play a rape victim and like win an
oscar and like all these things
like i didn't know that i was gonna be
funny
and um so i i feel like
stand-up kind of chose me and if i was
bombing i wouldn't
have kept going you know but i did have
some bombs so like
probably one of my biggest bombs was a
corporate show
but who does show um
this was in las vegas and
it was for a trucking company where
90 of the employees are male
my fan base is predominantly women um
women respond to the things that i talk
about more so than men
so we get to this corporate event not
only is cards are stacked against me
because it's mostly dudes
but like truck driver dudes yeah
i don't think they wanna hear about
getting your nails done um
not only that they were currently in the
bar
like with a dj and music and all that
kind of stuff they stop the music
and they go everybody come over here to
this conference room and we're gonna
have our stand-up comedian now
and i was like oh no and um my opener
goes up first and i was like well you
know what at least they'll like him
because he's a dude so at least they'll
get to laugh for him and then i'll just
figure it out he gets on stage
bombing just they don't even like him
and i was like oh this is gonna be
horrible they're gonna hate me
i get on stage um not one laugh
go to the next joke not one laugh not
even chuckles
and it's like wow okay let me go
straight to like my oakland raiderette
material
because um i there's some like football
jokes in there so that's you know some
guy stuff so at least i'll laugh
at the football jokes i make fun of the
readers like everybody can laugh at the
raiders
and then um i talk about being a raider
and there's like you know a couple
things in there and maybe they'll be
excited that i'm a raider
or something like let me just not
material nothing
finally when i start making fun of
myself
for bombing and for being there when i
start saying things like listen guys
i didn't book me for this okay i don't
want to be here you don't want me to be
here
but i'm here like it's just what it when
i start making fun of
myself then i start getting chuckles
like
then i start making fun of the woman who
booked me and i was like girl
what were you thinking booking me for
this i am the absolute
worst person you have could have booked
for this party then they're laughing at
that
i was supposed to do 45 minutes i maybe
did 20 minutes and i look over at her
and i was like do you want me to keep
going and she was like
have a good night see you guys later and
got my check and went out the back door
still got paid hey you better believe it
i showed up i did my part
oh that's beautiful i love hearing the
bombing stories i feel like that's so
important for young comics to hear is
like
yeah she's this but every comic goes
through these trials on stage
oh for sure for sure i mean there's
shows
that i don't like where i'm like you
guys are the worst
like but bombing like actual like the
one i just
shared with you those were like far few
in between
um but there's definitely been shows
where i'm like
are you guys not a bad mood did you
decide together to be in a bad mood
before you came to the show
because i don't like you guys so
i'm cutting my show short so
i'm just like actual time and that's it
exactly
oh i've done colleges and corporate gigs
where i'm just like
all right tick tock on the check you
know i'm not saying it out loud but i am
just like
[Laughter]
exactly and to think about like getting
booked in the business side
and uh we do have some people asking
questions but i did want to ask you
about the
your business sense because you're like
you're very savvy even with like
bon kwekui it could have been a
character
that you're known for on stage doing
stand-up but then
i think your husband inspires you to
create an album and then you go on tour
and there's merchandising and the
business side like
show business you seem to have a really
good grasp of both
what what business tips could you share
with this next generation of comics
well i think um we're all
you're always needing to evolve and grow
in your business sense and i feel like
that's kind of where i am now
currently is looking at others and it's
that fine line
of when you're looking to learn
and when you're looking because you're
just comparing yourself now
that's where it's dangerous so i watch
and learn and i see other comics and i'm
like
okay they're popping off right now like
what are they doing how did they do that
what are the ins and outs of that and i
start wondering so you can just sit in
that wonder
and be like ah i could never figure that
out i don't know how to even start with
that
or you could pick up a phone and you can
call
if you don't know that person directly
maybe you know somebody who works with
them and say hey what was it like
when you all filmed that thing like who
put that together
did you hire a production company like
how did that work
and be humble enough to ask questions
and
to not come in as like um
comparing or competing but like hey what
can i learn
from you like humbling yourself and how
did you do that
can you share how you did that how many
of us comics
actually reach out to each other and say
how did you do that not many
yeah so i feel like it's really humbling
yourself
and watching and learning and when you
see somebody doing something that
is intriguing to you that you're like i
would want to do something like that
then
maybe send him a dm and say hey
um you're probably busy i'm sure but
love what you've been doing
just curious like how did you get
started filming sketches
like what would be the first step to
take any anything you could
offer would be greatly appreciated i
think you're hilarious big fan
take care like that's it and then maybe
they respond to you maybe they don't
maybe they're like oh yeah i uh i
watched and learned from
eric schwartz eric schwartz filming all
his own stuff has his own green screen
in his house and like all the things
like
oh yeah maybe um i went on the road with
so and so and they taught me how to
record my own show and
and upload it to youtube
so i just started doing that oh okay
cool
like using each other as resources
because there's enough room for all of
us
to be successful like when you start
hoarding
your knowledge hoarding your wisdom
hoarding information for what
you already learned it it's in you share
it if you don't share it while you're
afraid they're gonna pass you up because
they took your wisdom and passed you up
that's their time that's their journey
then don't worry about what they're
doing
you you learned this now what else can
you learn learn something new you're
gonna ask this person give me advice on
this okay cool and then this person's
gonna ask you can you give me advice on
this
yes this is what i did yes
i love that yeah that you i love your
collaborative your community mindset
if someone is doing something you want
to do ask them how they did it that's
really what this podcast is in a lot of
ways
an excuse to do that exactly
exactly this is the non-um not
confrontational like
there's no no risk in listening to
your podcast and hearing somebody give
advice there's no risk in that
but maybe risk in other things and
send a dm send a text pick up the phone
whatever you can
and same thing offer what you know to
somebody else
hmm amen
so um speaking of collaborating with
others this could be a good
question coming in from robin sutton
clark
asking have you ever been sabotaged by
another woman
in comedy out of competition for the
limited number of slots
for women and how do you rebuild that
bridge
um i've never been sabotaged
i remember there was this one time i did
it a set
at a local club and um
i was practicing my late night set
which i didn't even end up booking after
all but
did you get bummed putting it no i
i put my show together and submitted it
and they came back with notes on my set
but the notes that they
said to me i felt was rewriting my joke
and i wasn't going to do that
and they thought it was just like yeah
can you maybe make it more like this and
i was like
oh like rewrite my joke no i'm good
thank you though bye
um so i never did it was that good or
bad but i don't know
but i just wasn't willing to
change talk about self-awareness though
most of us would bend to the will of a
late night show yeah whatever you say
for sure
yeah yeah that is funnier good idea good
idea exactly
um so i was practicing my late night set
at this one club
and um it was like okay
how do you want to be introduced and i
was like oh you could just say
um she has a nail salon joke
and she has her special or something i
forget what it was but it was very like
hey could you say this nails on
chocolate whatever um
she goes on stage to introduce me before
she introduces me
she does her own version of a nail salon
joke
and i was all oh
okay that's that's weird
i just told her that okay let's see
maybe she was planning on doing that the
whole time who cares
then when she introduces me it wasn't
like
she has a special on whatever blah blah
blah it was
all right this next comment come to say
she says she has a special
and i was all i do you could stream it
[Laughter]
i was like oh my god and
i had never been
like um treated that way but it was like
subtle but not it was like one of those
things where like
in girl talk like if a girl who is not
your friend
says like oh sweetie she told me you're
sweet
that's her trying to be like you're so
cute
like that's that it was a little bit i
had never been treated that way before
and i was like oh my god the heck
i didn't know this person at all do you
know them now
yeah so i'll come back around to that
part so i get up and i do my set
and then everybody laughs everybody knew
who i was everybody knew my nail salon
joke was like why would you waste your
time doing a nail sound joke when you
know i'm about to come up and be
the nail salon joke like why would you
do that to yourself
at that point but anyway so i did my set
left
never talked to her again for years and
years years i was like screw that girl
oh you do you go have fun whatever i'm
gonna live my life
years later we have mutual friends
i run into her at an event and i'm just
keeping my distance from her hey
how are you doing my little thing and
then she came up to me later in the
night
and apologized to me and
didn't address specifically when i said
this and blah blah blah
but it was more so i apologize
if i've ever said anything to offend you
or
disrespect you wow thank you i
appreciate that
so now if i see her we say what's up
um i'll like like posts here and there
and leave like a nice comment stuff like
that but
we're not like friends or anything who
is it
do we know her i i don't know i
you probably do but i would never say a
name
i love it though yeah it's unnecessary
energy to even put out there
so yeah i appreciate that but you know
as a journalist you know i'm gonna
i'm not a journalist i'm a comic with a
podcast but um
to to get into i'm getting journalism
here
we're getting a lot of good stuff people
don't know about you though this is
great
is when it comes to your characters uh
and sandra's asking this
i've heard you say bon kwekui is like
your brother and a lady you met at a
memphis burger king um
how what is your process for developing
characters you find
common grounds like yeah what is yeah
how do you actually develop a character
that people connect with
here's the funny thing about that i
don't know
because i don't really do characters
like
bunk weekly is really my only character
that i developed from mad tv
but i never did like second city or
groundlings or whatever to
learn how to fully develop sketch
characters like i don't know how to do
that
but in my my stand-up in my writing i
like to do a lot of act outs
and so within that
i start giving whatever person that i'm
talking about
um character but most of the people i'm
talking about are real people
it's my brother it's my sister it's my
grandpa it's my dad
it's my mom so i take their real essence
and talk about them on stage but
bonkwiki is really
and and tammy is not even really a
character either the nail salon like
like she's um the person that i interact
with in the story but i don't like
develop her out and give her like
dimensions you know she's she's a
character in a story
whereas bonquinkly is the only one that
actually
like lived on as her own person with you
can tell this is how long
he thinks this is the things that she'll
say this is where she came from
this is like you'll know all of that but
like with tammy you don't know how
what her opinion is about this you can
probably guess what bunk weekly's
opinion is
about donald trump about whatever
you know what i mean um but
bon kwekui yes was a mix of my brother
and um this girl at the burger king
in memphis tennessee but my brother
before he got sober so gone quickly is
my brother before he got sober
oh my brother was like
no filter he would say
what everyone was thinking in the back
of their mind but would never say out
loud
so like people would go when he would
say things but at the same time they're
like oh my god
i was totally thinking that but i would
never say it like he was that guy
he is so funny and he would make up his
own slang
in his own things and when he would say
something all his friends started saying
it right after him
and that's kind of like who bonkwik we
is she makes up
a slang word whatever it is she starts
doing a thing
everybody starts doing a thing and
that's my brother
my brother would start laughing a
certain way all his friends
all his co-workers now everyone laughs
like him because he started doing this
now the whole workplace everybody goes
because it's their thing he would just
do things
and it was like sassy and it was
funny and no filter so a lot of things
that bonquiqui would say
early on from my brother's mouth
my brother would say it and i would go
oh my god don't think he's gonna say
that
done in her mouth like so that's what
where it's like
he was my biggest inspiration for it and
then her working at king burger and
being like
the rude employee was the employee that
i experienced in memphis tennessee who i
was like so
i couldn't believe i was like oh my god
this is real life you're a real person
you're really saying these things to me
okay
this is i've never experienced this and
it just stuck in my memory
and that was when i was in high school
like i was like 17 when i
had experienced that in memphis
tennessee and then here i am in my 20s
writing about that experience through my
brother
whoa so that it burned in your brain i
figured this was after you're pursuing
comedy but this is
not even a comic but you're traumatized
by this person
yes yes
so you just pull like real life traits
from people and then just put them all
into one character
yeah pretty much it makes sense you know
yeah
you make it sound so easy well thank you
i mean again like i really just have
that one character
all the rest are stories that i tell you
know
they're all personal though which is
which is great and what all comics
really strive for
um let's see a few more questions here
are you good can you do a few more
questions
of course of course um
ooh hulen saunders asks if you could
tour with one comedian dead or alive
right now who would it be
i mean
honestly i love my friend joe coy and we
did
a little bff tour years ago
and it did not do well but we
on purpose because i was doing well on
my own he was doing well on his own so
we're like let's go to the markets where
neither one of us do well
and like try to build that together that
was a great plan of all time
it didn't go well it didn't know but um
we were both this is like years and
years ago so we were both like
doing well in clubs you know um
and it was fun because i love joe
he loves me we have such a great
friendship like we're hilarious together
like we
we have so much fun together like that
if we could have done that
more places and had more fun and gone
around the world like that would have
been amazing like if i could just
open for him now like all the things
that he's doing now on his own
if he would just let me come and hang
out i would do that
how bad did it get though you're saying
the tour didn't really work like are we
talking like
we did two cities we didn't do anymore
what were the sales like oh
awful we did a theater in detroit
and not even the bottom half
was like it was awful
we i was like how did they even let us
show up they should have canceled the
show before we got here what are we
doing here
but it was fun i think we did detroit in
minneapolis maybe
i don't remember the second show i think
it was minneapolis
but yeah we had a great time like
hanging out and having fun
and our show was great and
and we did oh and we did one more more
recently
so that was like when we weren't doing
we were doing well
but like he wasn't where he's at now
and then i was like selling out clubs
but wasn't really
hitting the theaters hard yet then maybe
it was like three years ago or four
years ago
maybe three years ago he and i did a
show in
florida and that was fire and we were
both already like
both of us could have sold out that
venue by ourselves
but so we came together for that show
and it was like we were co-headlining
that show so it was
it was a fun experience there
but um that was just like a one-off show
that we did together
but i love it's like two successful
comics you're like we're not good in
these markets maybe if we combine
forces and work together we could both
help each other it's like cool to even
see
comics successful headliners like both
of you still
looking to like reach across the aisle
and be like hey let's still help each
other that's
that's so important for us to understand
his comics
and it didn't work then but also
if we would have put the energy and time
and risk into
figuring out why didn't it work did we
not do the right press
did we not give enough lead time for
ticket sales like
if we took some time to figure out okay
why didn't we
why didn't this crack um it
we could have figured out why it worked
and made something work but you know
everything
happens for a reason and and it was
supposed to happen this way
but yes it's a great idea of reaching
across the aisle and
we can do it together you know and we
are
about to reach across the aisle of the
hot breath verse because the reason
you're on the show today
is because hot brethren bo johnson
reached out to your people reached out
to your team and made this interview
happen
and what i want to do just as a
gratitude is to actually bring him on
the show live
for him to meet you if you're good uh
hot brethren
is hilarious and yeah we got hot
brethren and sister in the hot breath
verse here
let's meet bo so let's welcome bo
johnson come on in
buddy welcome to the party here
[Music]
hey how are you good how are you doing
buddy
i'm doing good i'm in my normal spot
at work where do you work uh i work for
school
i was a teacher now i'm just a tech
associate um i kind of took a lower
lower paying job so i can make more time
for comedy nice
yeah so i just deal with computers all
day right now i'm in our newsroom
um to do this interview i took a very
late lunch so i could do this
wow thanks for squeezing it in here bo
do you have any questions for angela
um well you know actually since our
first interview we did together joel you
said you seem to take up my big
questions
um but she i think he's
even admitted that he does that um well
he told me his questions ahead of time
like the nail salon lady did for you and
i was like i'm gonna do all of those
questions to sabotage his set
yeah yeah exactly yeah community it's
not exactly
it's that i just feed him all the
information
like a really good producer um but
but it's interesting that you said that
um you went to hollywood to be an
actress
and then it just like comedy chose you
yeah um
how did that come about like like when
did you
figure out like okay this is what i'm
supposed to do instead well let me tell
you i'm still trying to be an actress
um i
i'll tell you exactly when it changed
for me so i did the whole
class had the viral video it was like
going around like crazy
um i was doing little spots here and
there around town
uh at the improv or at like buzz cafe or
at this little bar
or whatever like um
and then somebody hit me up on myspace
remember amaze me
somebody hit me up on myspace and was
like hey would you like to perform
at our mormon christmas party
and i was like sure but i'm not mormon
and they were like oh no it's okay we
just need clean comedians
and i was like okay yeah i could do that
and then um so when i get there they
have like 10 other comics there
and they're like okay we're actually
doing a comedy competition
and whoever wins gets like a cash prize
and i was like oh
okay yeah sounds great let's do it
so i do this comedy competition and i
tied for first place so we split the
money and i won
600 this was
the most money i had ever made in my
entire life
in like one day in like doing a thing
like i would get a 600
paycheck i'll tell you this month my
whole paycheck for the oakland raiders
when i was a cheerleader for the oakland
raider rents we went to the super bowl
that year was the best year to pick to
be a super bowl
i got paid 585 for that whole season
here i am just did 15 minutes of
stand-up comedy
at a mormon christmas party and they
gave me 600
it blew my mind to the point where i was
like wait
you could get paid this much money doing
stand-up
i'm gonna be a stand-up comedian and
that's kind of when it switched to me i
was like if i could make 600
every show i'm gonna try doing the
stand-up thing i'm gonna do that
and that's kind of when it shifted for
me and i started because before i was
like i'm not a stand-up comedian i just
do this for fun
i'm an actress and then after that kind
of shifted and i was like
oh i'm trying to be a stand-up comedian
but also i'm trying to be an actress too
and then it kind of became like stand up
what
is what blew up and just the doors kept
flying open for stand-up comedy stuff
and the whole time i'd be on the road
like doing shows i was still looking
over my shoulder back at hollywood like
are you ready for me yet and i was like
nope
not yet i'm like okay well i'm still on
the road
and i would come home for pilot season
and like book one but then the pilot
didn't get picked up so i'm like all
right
back on the road you know so yeah i
moved here to be an actress but once i
went to a mormon christmas party
changed my whole ways
wow that is interesting so what is your
writing process like
um i talk to myself i talk out loud and
then i record it
um if i make somebody laugh
from an original thought that i just had
i will write that thought down
in my notes if i remember it like
sometimes i'm just in the moment and
just having fun and then
other times i'm like oh that's funny let
me write that down real quick
um like for instance i was on facetime
the other day with my cousin it was her
birthday i just called her tell her
happy birthday
and um she said something
about getting a covet test and she was
explaining how it felt
and then i was like tagging her
story with funny things and i was like
oh
i'm gonna write this down because your
story
with my tags is funny like she was just
telling me like uh and then this and
then that and then i would say something
funny to it
and then she was cracking up and then
she would tell me more details and i
would say something funny to that and
she was cracking up i was like you know
let me write this down really quick
so it's like moments like that um
or it's rarely ever something funny
happens
and i go oh i'm gonna talk about this
funny thing that happened it's a
normal thing that happens and my funny
perspective on the normal thing
yeah it's rarely ever like going to get
your nails done is not hilarious
but when you notice and observe
that they're upselling me and they're
doing it real secretively
like how do you ninja upsell me
like you just complimented me of how i'm
so pretty and then you got me to pay six
dollars more how'd you do that
like observation and highlighting
that is what's funny but just going to
get your nails done it's not fun
that's funny because i actually had a
vietnamese student whose parents owned a
nail salon
and he actually did whatever they do go
from english to vietnamese
it's a 90 chance they're talking crab
about you right now
i've heard that a lot too from my i have
friends who own nail salons
they told me that they're like for sure
i brought my
growing up one of my best friends was
vietnamese and so i took him with me to
the nail salon
and was like okay you're gonna tell me
what is happening and he's like for sure
yeah they're for sure talking about you
but
i'm sure there's times they're not but
i in my own case study that i did i was
given very pertinent information that
this is what you said about you i'm like
i see you girl that's what you really
think about me tina okay all right then
wow that's that is interesting so with
all the women that are watching right
now
um what advice would you have for them
do you and do you well and that's for
everybody that's men and women
that's you're trying to be a comedian
you're trying to be something else try
to be an actress you're trying to own
your own
bakery whatever it is do you
and do you well to the best of your
ability
because there's nobody else like you
there's nobody else with your childhood
there's nobody else
with your part-time job there's nobody
else with
your car that you drive that breaks down
all the time there's nobody else
with um your abuse there's nobody else
with your faith
there is nobody else that has all the
ingredients to the recipe that make
you someone may have this part in this
part but they don't have these parts
they may have this and that but they
don't have the rest of the parts
so you as a person are so unique and
special that nobody
has you so when i go into an audition
and they're
auditioning for detective rodriguez i
guarantee you
when i get there there's going to be 10
other girls that look just like me
and we're all going to be wearing a
leather jacket some jeans and boots
guarantee you because that's our
detective rodriguez outfit
and when i get there and walk in i can
get in my head and be like
oh my gosh where i'm at i'm a dozen look
at there's all of us
like they're probably gonna like her
better because she's taller and she
looks more tough so they're probably
gonna like her better probably gonna
like this one better because i've seen
her on tv
before so she probably had more credits
than me like
i can get in my head about that or i can
know and trust that when i walk into the
audition room and when i say the same
words
that all the 10 other girls are saying
they're all going and saying the same
words that i'm saying
i know that when i say them i am saying
them with
all the ingredients of me behind it so
it sounds different it feels different
it comes off different
the look that i give with my trauma
behind it my childhood behind it
is different than the way this girl did
it who's taller than me
because i am me so when you show up and
do
you don't try to be the tall girl don't
try to be this one who's been on tv
before when you
show up and do you and do you well
to the best of your ability don't hold
back don't let fear keep you stuck but
you go
and you confront your fears and you go
past that and you show up and you do you
to the best of your ability
then that's when magic happens that's
when you're
undeniable because you're living in your
true authentic
most highest self wow that's great
that's for everybody
any others bo no that that just
that just set out that said it all yeah
how do you discover what you do well
you what makes you happy what makes
other people happy around you that you
do
you know if you took your own pizza
dough
and every time you make pizza and your
friends come over and like hey next time
you make pizza call me i love it maybe
there's something special in that
maybe think about that you know
everybody's like oh my gosh every time
you come over
like and you're talking about
this it's so inspiring every time i have
a conversation with you you're so
inspiring maybe there's something in
that maybe you're good at inspiring
people
and coaching people and advising people
who knows i don't know
like whatever makes you happy and other
people around you happy
there's probably a strength in that boom
awesome that's awesome well thanks for
uh thanks for all the help here bo
hey thank you for making this around me
to come on and thank you friend
angela thanks for nominating me to be on
the podcast i don't know if it's because
we share the last name or what
hey that's a it's a powerful last name
it's a great last name
but knowing that you are such a popular
um comic right now and even when i told
my daughters like guess who i'm
interviewing today
angela johnson i want to watch
so it's like because you you you have
this power to resonate with a lot of
people and so i was like okay
we have i have to make it my mission to
get you on this show so
thank you well tell your daughters i say
hello or if they're watching this hello
thank you for being fans yeah they are
big
they are huge fans when i when i told
them they were like there's just no way
i want to see this i want to be a part
of it
well that means i can't take off work
and come home to do this because you
will zoom bomb the whole thing so
[Laughter]
tell your daughters to subscribe to the
youtube
now we're doing call to actions
right we'll drive up subscriptions
well i'm glad we could share this moment
bo that means even more now that i know
that your daughters were so
like into it as well that's awesome yeah
i mean they were they were very
well i've been trying to look around and
see who's who's really
you know in everybody's viewpoint and
who people are looking up to and
um how young who you young comics can
you know get the best advice from
and so i was like okay let's see if i
can get angela on this will probably be
like the biggest
person i get on to our show so yeah
and you did it thank you for inviting me
nice job thank you for coming on
thanks buddy all right thank you all
have a great day all right you too buddy
bye angela
bye see joel see ya all right
well let's land this plane here
uh miss miss johnson here um the final
um
it seems like the you do you i usually
ask comics to end with like
their favorite advice for comedians but
it sounds like yours may be that you do
well do you have any other kind of
closing advice for comics
i mean that's pretty much it that's i
like to
leave out on the floor for people um
and then i would say just based on this
interview alone what came out of me
was a lot about confronting your fears
and not letting your fear hold you back
whether that's fear of failure
fear of networking
fear of disappointment
fear of anything really
just don't let fear keep you stuck or
even keep you
like lower like you could be way up here
if you confronted your fear so it's not
like you're stuck like you're still
going at this pace but if you just said
you know what who cares
and confront that fear and you like
shake the weight off of the fear and
then you go faster when you're not
carrying all that weight
um well you've helped a lot of comics
today angela
um foreign i get to do that thank you
for for comics who may be watching this
later would you mind
like looking into the camera saying your
name and why comics should listen to hot
breath
hey i'm angela johnson reyes and you
should listen to hot breath because
you're gonna walk away with a lot of
good
information inspiration motivation
all the asians are on this show so you
should really check it out
oh well thank you let's give angela a
round of applause here that is a loud
sound effect i just did for people on
the podcast sorry yes yes
uh where can people um support you
follow you also are there any my mom
want to ask this are there any causes
near and dear to your heart that maybe
we can help support as well
yes i sit on the board of an anti-human
trafficking organization
it is called unlikely heroes you can
check them out unlikelyheroes.com
you can go to their instagram which is
you heroes
um h-e-r-o-e-s um
and yeah so rescuing rescuing
women and children from sex slavery um
and you can you can find
me on instagram angela johnson on
instagram
i do a ghost stories turning it into a
podcast but it's like
a live show on youtube and facebook and
stuff we do it every other friday
um you can check out archived episodes
on my youtube channel and it's just
ghost stories with angela
and i bring on a special guest each
episode
a lot of comedians have come on a couple
of my actor friends have come on
um and they share a ghost story with me
and then i take calls from fans and fans
will jump on to my live and
kind of like we just had beau on they
will come on and share their story
of a real ghost interaction that they
had
so that's ghost stories with angela i
have a podcast that's called knights at
the round table
which is more of a faith
relationship deconstruction
of all of those things and
reconstruction of all of those things so
it's kind of a deeper podcast where i
take a look at
my faith and what i believe and why i
believe it and what i don't believe
anymore
and um and relationships
it's my husband and myself and one of
our best friends brandon
and we come and we interview different
people from different walks of life but
a lot of times it's just us
talking about you know what why how has
politics ruined the church and that kind
of stuff
we we're not a political podcast by any
means
but like that was like one episode where
we're talking we talk about our faith so
we're like okay like there's a lot of
people leaving the church because y'all
are like pledging allegiance to
politics and not just god you know
like you are you worshiping god or the
president which one you're gonna do
pickling kids you can't do both
you know and so saying some things like
that that you're not really hearing in
church and asking some questions that
maybe in church you're not supposed to
ask this question and we're like
wait a minute are you really not
supposed to do this
like is that like real faith or is that
just christian culture
that we have adopted as gospel like
whatever
so we talk about that kind of stuff and
and just like is it okay
to check out someone else if you're
married like what's that like and
whatever yeah i don't know if people
understand how like
your transition from like you like you
wrote jokes and then went viral but in
between there
you're living on granola bars and
cheerios and ramen
and you're actually working on your
faith in that moment and it you said
that it like
almost prepared you for the success you
had because you were working on that
faith journaling praying like
listening to music you really cultivated
that relationship
and do you credit that for what like
created this success i mean that seemed
like a very pivotal moment in your
career
definitely part of the foundation for
sure
um when you build your
business on a solid foundation it helps
it to
sustain longer you know as opposed to
building it in sand or building it with
you know oh you didn't put the right
beams in you didn't put the right bars
and whatever
like for me all of those things like
praying
and journaling and all of that are just
like steel beams going into my
foundation
so not necessarily the credit goes to
these things that
made me who i am but definitely part of
the foundation that's building me up
stronger building my character building
like who i am like stand for something
or you fall for anything you know like
that whole thing
um and even that has evolved like the
things that i stand for the things
that i believe the things that i
proclaim
have evolved over the years and so it's
kind of
that message as well beautiful all right
well we have we have taken up enough of
your time
angela this was amazing we will link all
of the the causes you said as well as
like all your social media and your
podcasts and
we'll be sure to link all that in the
show notes for people to support but
thank you for helping the next
generation of comics here angela
my pleasure thank you for having me all
right everyone have a good day out there
hot breath averse
you